the eyes to the right 327 the nose to  the left  299 so the eyes of it  the eyes have it unlocked order yes  point of order mr. Hillary man thank you  very much indeed mr. speaker the house  has spoken to see if the other place  passes the bill then I say to the Prime  Minister that this house expects him to  uphold the law and to fulfill the  obligations that will be placed upon him  by this bill and prevent this country  from leaving the European Union on the  31st of October without a deal may I  also mr. speaker thank the clerks for  their assistance right honourable  gentlemen dorset West and others for  their great help and they are also  joined my right honourable friend the  member for hope and some pancreas in  most warmly applauding the bravery and  the courage of many on that side of them  who have stood by their convictions in  the national interest  [Applause]